for your final two levels of competition
generic competition and budget
competition think larger scale now
generic competition includes products
and services that fulfill the same
customer needs so a generic competition
for our flavored water here would be any
other drink that our potential customer
can choose so regular water sparkling
water juice tea sports drinks sodas you
get the picture budget competition
includes all products and services that
compete for the same amount of money
okay so while let's think about that
this is a two dollar and fifty cent
water in the Bay Area
so everything else it's two dollars and
fifty cents is our budget competitor so
this adorable stuffed monkey a sponge
pack a trading card some breakfast
cereal some pencils some post-its a
hamburger and fries you get the picture
now for more expensive items in the
budget category like let's say an
engagement ring you might be competing
for a car or a down payment or to a
house or part of it or vacation you get
the picture just think larger scale